hello and welcome to this video st off
85 91 so what do we get so yeah let's
see I get the hood no variation it seems
I get it that's one of my my real pet
lines mm-hmm always feel like personally
offended if I lose it they'll lose a
game with it but it does happen of
course so II for or one of the slower
moves white tends to play Waiting see a
Quincy to rugby 1 92 92 wisdom main move
have white is not going for your form
aha seems is trying to find my book on
the dems Oh somewhere sitting on his
shelf almost hear the pages turning and
I'm probably not
hmm yeah well what can I say like normal
ego ce5 now after about every move that
wide place yeah like here yeah this is
also a line check okay interesting where
do I go now d 7 or where exactly yeah g6
looks like looks wrong in some in some
ways now on the other hand what is the
submission doing on 97 in the first
place probably not that much yeah the
thing is f4 f4 is coming okay so i think
i'll go back so that I'm ready for f4
okay now is playing out moves like
there's no tomorrow move move move move
move okay Gavin you just had something
to do we are answering the doorbell or
something like that okay anyway I'm
going with f5 now I guess I need to free
up the position always going f3 uh-huh
okay I'm happy to check of course my
can't dream scenario here is a minor
piece ending where I'm just winning the
you for porn mmm okay look f8 or not
Knight f6 is also already a possibility
or going for this may be going for this
just try to attack the porn directly
and Knight f6 next and I will see
keeping the pawn where'd you go what is
the most precise him this one I guess
and now what to know cannot do win that
time but ok I can go here yeah where do
I gets to g5 maybe to have night h5 and
possibly night F for the good thing is
that I always have a look at seven now
you have to cover the b7 pond I mean um
I actually wonder if I have to cover
that night h5 looks already pretty
strong
okay let's go lazy chess yeah I mean
it's just playing move off to move off
to move what is this now it's going back
to be one then or I don't know looks
pretty awful also threatened night h5m
quite resigned hmm I'm not quite sure
why actually but I'm happy to take the
point I ok I'm clearly better but I
thought it was a bit bit bit early yeah
okay that is hanging the bishop on the
on d3 ok let's go back a little bit um
yeah that liner with 92 94 it's erm is
playable it's not very very common but
it's a it's a playable option now it
took um there's also this move it's
quite quite funny it looks like white
wins a pawn after this even that it's
not entirely clear but I can go here and
then actually two pieces I hanging
something like this is in fact a line
that white can play in three pawns for
the piece it's probably not great but
but an option yeah hey to play deform
yeah debatable I went to g6 and to have
the d7 square for the night and with
this idea because I expected him to play
something like f4 or let's say it's
something that you have to take into
account no I can take Bishop jigs and go
Knight to d7 this is why i went with
Bishop g6 so that d7 is a free square
for the night so that now night will
come to e5 and here black has a pretty
good position I think okay didn't do a
form that which is of course justified
yeah that I'm exactly ready for for this
okay push the apron up the board and we
should be 35 somehow my software won't
play it here and f3 was was played in
one second and is just losing probably
strategically and it's pretty clear once
you take a little bit of time and make
an effort here and not just play a move
randomly and thing is if he takes which
which he has to do of course the
position opens up and in fact yes Scott
Quinn be one which
didn't see ya so actually f5 was
mistimed now thats I mean what he played
was strategically bad but also not
taking into account that f5 was actually
Miss time they have to play this first
and only then f5 aha yeah that was much
better so f3 is so is a it says in two
ways a big mistake it didn't take use of
my premature f5 and it leads to a
strategically very bad position and the
thing is that now this pawn is a very
convenient target for my pieces and he
has nothing adequate in return he has
got nothing else at he can attack my
pawn structure he has completely sound
and cannot be attacked in any way for
example any minor piece and game if we
just have knights and bishops on the
board um I ok I have night and Bishop
when he's got two bishops and I just go
Knight f6 and this is falling and this
is the winning idea now I can just
detect the poem and he has a hard time
to cover it yeah Quincy 296 or that was
played immediately yeah I now AM went
here night h5 is already an interesting
option I wasn't completely sure and
played the the safe the safe way but she
adds it's not easy for him to move I
mean what is he doing this is attacked
if he takes on b7 this was actually was
what was not completely clear to me if
I'm having something something super
convincing ham takes gigs this
check check check no he's checking me
like no tomorrow yeah I played the lazy
move but it is also not bad White has
some very little that he can do okay he
went there immediately and Queen d2 yep
now there's a stuff hanging Plus this
one yeah he can continue with Queen B 1
and then I'm starting to take pawns it
is pretty bad but I don't know why you
exactly had to resign them yeah f5 was
mistimed actually I should it's an
interesting motif actually that I wasn't
aware of that sorry that this is
actually a double attack and it's
something that it's it's an interesting
motif and absolutely have no move to to
keep both covered so it's just not just
not possible as it's really awful if it
would be seven porn faults it's pretty
awful okay I was lucky that he was an
instant move mode the whole time okay
thanks for watching